in contrast to its shown in jumpers
bleeds brought about a unique flair and
swagger with its mature art themes and
characters starring teens and set in a
world not too different from our own
bleach aesthetically set itself apart
from its contemporaries such as Naruto
while attracting a huge fanbase the
anime series made waves all over the
world firmly establishing itself as one
of the pillars of Shonen anime back in
the early mid 2000s with the ending
almost a decade ago I'm not sure if many
people still have fond memories of the
show and that's precisely what this
video is for why don't we take a trip
down memory lane and take a look at some
of the top moments in Bleach is storied
history
[Music]
of course a top-10 list of memorable
moments wouldn't be complete without the
one that started it all
it should go becoming a Shinigami to sum
up the main character Ichigo Kurosaki's
life changes in an encounter with the
Shinigami Rukia Kuchiki when a hollow
attacks the Kurosaki household Rukia
gets injured with him as their only hope
Ichigo accepts the responsibility and
lets Rukia stab him transferring her
powers to him and turning him into the
substitute Shinigami it's a strong and
powerful image that fittingly kicks off
this epic supernatural adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
next is Aizen battling the captains and
visits in fake ah recruit au need more
proof that Aizen is by far one of the
most broken villains ever conceived in
anime history look no further from this
whole sequence in fake kuru kuru town
after the united front of the goatier
and the visits finished taking care of
business should be easy right aizen's
counts down to him and Ginn and he has a
whole bunch of powerful opponents ready
to gang up on him the battle starts and
he easily dispatches a few captain
however the numbers game would
eventually catch up to him and he finds
himself finished off by hitsugaya in
poetic fashion not when were you under
the impression that Aizen can be done in
by lowly captain's and visits that don't
even comprehend his power and he's only
getting stronger and stronger as the
battle rages on
[Applause]
[Music]
orihime is the next moment the one where
she says goodbye to Ichigo you see or he
made powers have put her in eyes and
sights Aizen sends various forces to act
as a diversion the one who finally
intercepts the girl is none other than
his fourth Espada okie Ora threatened by
ulquiorra
Orihime agrees to go with him to hueco
mundo however for someone who's the
embodiment of nihilism the Espada isn't
as heartless after all
instead of taking a straight to Aizen
ulquiorra allows Orihime to say her
farewells to one person without anyone
else's knowledge Ora he made the choice
is clear as day finding herself inside
her choices room for the first time she
confesses her love to her sleeping
Ichigo in her confession she tells him
of her dreams and reaffirms her love for
him this is a dramatic scene that sets
the stage for the next dog the scene
where ar-rahim a can't bring herself to
kiss Ichigo and the confession that
follows remains for me one of the key
scenes for this girl in the entirety of
bleach you can't help but feel sad for
her as she says her supposed last
farewell
[Music]
Kouros commission ET lunare another idea
although this year in a seventh place is
Ginn's betrayal of eysan talk about top
10 anime betrayal or what for me one of
the moments that struck me the most as I
watched the end of the eysan arc is the
scene where gain Pierce's his sword
right through aizen's chest he reveals
the trick to playing around kyoka
suigetsu as well as the true nature of
his bankai
it's here that Ginn's true intentions
are revealed all this time it's spent
being by eyes inside establishing him as
a close ally everything is for the sole
purpose of exacting revenge on this man
for rank EKU's sake how fitting that
even his bankers name can be translated
to God killing spear it's as if Ginn's
been destined to kill eysan all along
all is for naught as eysan revives
almost immediately and puts a quick end
to Ginn's ambitions Ginn spends his last
moments lamenting his failure and
apologizing to rangiku on a more hopeful
note he lives long enough to see Ichigo
emerge out of the dumb guy upon seeing
the fire of resolving the teens eyes
Ian finally dies knowing that he can
leave the rest to Ichigo undergo an
iconic rhetorical Serato mother Monica
[Music]
next up it's Ichigo arriving at Kara
kuru town to fight Aizen just as Aizen
seems unstoppable and all hope seems
lost out of the down guy comes none
other than Ichigo gone is the hesitant
youth with shaky resolve and the Ichigo
that wavered against Kim's relentless
assault thanks to the time he trained
inside the dumb guy Ichigo stands before
Aizen a completely mature and confident
combatant one doesn't have to look
anywhere but his appearance to see proof
of a man who's been through hell and
back thanks to the training Ichigo has
transcended his limits far beyond what
Aizen has become to further at this
point ichigo simply grabs Aizen and
throws him down in order to have a fight
where the two of them wouldn't be
interrupted one does not simply
manhandle Aizen like that it's finally
time for the final showdown
that's vales and eyes
yonder porosity our Sugano getsuga
tensho Terra
what it is
kids again United number five is of
course the final getsugatensho the
battle against aizen's being going well
so far
breaking enhanced Aikido with his arm
check destroying the landscape with a
swing of his sword check to cap it off
he also returns a year-long favor to
Aizen by stopping Aizen sword with his
hand with Aizen reeling and shaking in
disbelief
ichigo decides that it's time to finish
the fight once and for all it's here
that he unveils the culmination of his
dango trading the final getsugatensho in
terms of hype nothing really compares to
seeing it to go with an ominous aura and
sleek new attire in his bid to finally
defeat the overpowered villain in anime
his finisher mu getsu is especially
important because it's a move that
eliminates the last traces of a
Shinigami power once he's used it it's
truly an all-or-nothing attack that
seeks to end Aizen before the latter can
continue evolving past ichigo's power
levels
easily taking the fourth spot on this
list is Ichigo interrupting rukia's
execution talk about coming in the nick
of time right as rookie us about to be
executed it she goes saves the day by
stepping between the giant fiery Phoenix
and Rukia pandemonium follows for soul
society's forces two senior captains
who've had their suspicions make their
move disabling the sokyoku and
confronting head captain Yamamoto more
importantly Ichigo succeeds in doing the
thing that he set off to do rescuing
Brooke iya after leaving Rukia and Renji
scare and easily defeating the vise
captains all that's left for Ichigo is
his date with destiny give you a new
door nice
for our third moment ichigo vs byakuya
'he's a shoo-in what makes the ichigo vs
byakuya fight so great you asked it's
important to note that this fight
happened way before character powers
went over the top and fight started
becoming predictable reveal fests where
the one who runs out of new powers loses
what we have here is a fight that pits
two of the key players in the story
together letting them face off in a
clean one-on-one fight with everything
on the line ichigo had just saved
Brooker in one chain of badass moments
meanwhile byakuya was never over hyped
like Aizen
but he's considered a very powerful
opponent and his fresh off making
mincemeat how this vice-captain had just
obtained bankai more than a battle of
strengths this fight is also a clash of
ideals Ichigo and byakuya as fight at
the end of the soul society arc would go
down as one if not the best fight in
Bleach history the action is
back-and-forth with Ichigo showcasing
his new bank I that lived up to the hype
and knocked the proud captain down a peg
situated or that Danner journeyed on
even under
Oh Maya Darla ichigo's full holo
transformation finds its way to the
second spot on the list throughout most
of the hueco mundo arc ichigo's done a
pretty good part in playing the underdog
the final fight against ulquiorra in
particular showed how outmatched and
outclassed ichigo is a dramatic moment
in that fight is when Orakei mate and
Ishida chase after the two combatants
only to be greeted with the sight of all
key aura delivering the finishing blow
to our protagonist blasting a hole
through his chest hearing Orihime cries
of despair something awakened within the
practically dead Ichigo his inner hollow
now taking over the hosts body the
hollow turns the tables and destroys all
key aura in one chilling sequence of
events even a secret technique gets
brushed aside by this incredible force
that aims to destroy everything in sight
if you ever wondered what a completely
unleashed hollow Ichigo can do look no
further from the episode featuring this
see
Tony Zion aizen's iconic review as a
traitor to soul society takes number one
on this list did you get caught
off-guard by this before a lot of us
sure did after spending most of the soul
society aren't dead Aizen turns up near
the end of the arc to the shock of
everyone for so long King's been the one
that's been set up as the orchestrator
of the arcs events
Kubo had other ideas and Ginn ends up
being just a co-conspirator all along to
demonstrate his power Aizen wastes no
time mowing through two captains bankai
hitsugaya and bank icon amaura both fall
to him in one hit and so he finally
finds himself face to face with Ichigo
and Renji the fight goes as well as
you'd expect after extracting the
hogyoku from Rukia Aizen gets forced
back temporarily along with his two
captain accomplices he leaves to a hueco
mundo and that's the last we saw of the
gentle bespectacled captain Aizen and
ichigo's theme seriously if memory
serves me right that's really the last
time we hear the vocal version of number
one guess Aizen killed the singer off to
and that's a wrap but honestly I feel
that I'm not done talking about bleach
throughout its decade-plus run bleach
had its share of ups and downs but it
definitely has no shortage of iconic and
epic moments ten entries just doesn't
cut it for this because this anime has
so much more to offer that can be
contained in just one video we will be
seeing a part two of this or would you
like to see a top 10 bleach fights video
if this video gets 5,000 likes I'll
definitely consider it if you're
interested in seeing more anime goodness
please take the time to like and
subscribe to vineet you
[Music]
[Music]